why otherwise capable and driven people  don't break through to the next level is  success  [Music]  and  this is how it works i first observed  this working with executive teams in  silicon valley and this is the process  the paradox of success is that when they  were focused on a few essential things  the right things they could get unified  behind it and so on and it coalesced to  momentum and with that they were able to  produce success  but success came with it options and  opportunities which although they're the  right problems they do turn out in fact  to be problems because they undermine  the very focus on essentials that led to  success in the first place  so i'm exaggerating the point  exaggerating the point in order to make  it but success can become a catalyst for  failure  [Music]  and if not that at least success can  become a catalyst for plateauing in our  progress  and suddenly we're just consumed with  all of the good things